just three days after the uvalde school
shooting trump headlined the nra's
national convention in houston and how
did he honor the victims
by awkwardly dancing on their graves
[Music]
okay before i start the segment here is
a list of items that i have officially
banned from my set just kidding those
were the items that were banned at the
nra's convention i can't believe i'm
saying this but they banned selfie
sticks okay who came up with this list
this is almost as ridiculous as jd vance
trying to ban porn or ted cruz trying to
ban dildos it's like
it's
wait
what if ted cruz did come up with this
list i mean dildos are technically
selfie sticks and it wouldn't be a trump
speech without him insulting others this
time he targeted abbott cornyn and
crenshaw after they decided not to
attend the nra convention and unlike
some i didn't disappoint you by not
showing up
when i first saw trump's speech i was
disgusted that he would even dare say
the names of the evaldi victims
but that quickly turned to shock mainly
because well i didn't know trump could
actually read here see for yourself
oops wrong video anyway this is the same
guy who said thailand yosemite in the
1775 revolutionary army took over
airports found glory across the waters
of the delaware and seized victory from
cornwallis of yorktown it took over the
airports it did everything it had to do
and in case you were wondering planes
were not used in warfare until the early
1900s
let alone airports okay here is trump
reading the victim's names alexandria
rubio
[Music]
alitha
ramirez
this whole thing feels like a scene from
a dystopian film you know the one where
the villain publicly reads the names of
his victims in the town square as a
warning
very dark stuff and during his speech
trump called for a series of measures to
prevent future mass shootings finally
harden our schools and protect our
children pardon schools
why does that sound so familiar
oh right it's because republicans have
been saying the same thing since the
parkland shooting in 2018. we have to
harden our schools not soften them up
most important thing we can do is harden
these schools harden the school
hardening schools hardened sites we have
to have hardened sites god help us
if we don't harden our schools
and protect our kids the thing is uvalde
did harden its schools in august 2020
law enforcement officers from five
agencies converged inside the hallways
of a school in uvalde texas their guns
drawn role-playing how they would halt a
gunman uvalde school officials were
doubling their budget for security
updating protocols and adding officers
to the district's police department and
despite the overhaul of security and
uvalde and across much of texas as well
as other states it has not stopped
school mass shootings in fact according
to a 2019 study there is no evidence
that hardening schools to make kids
safer from gun violence actually works
alright let's see what else trump has to
say every building should have a single
point of entry there should be strong
exterior fencing metal detectors and the
use of new technology to make sure that
no unauthorized individual can ever
enter the school with a weapon
wait what was that single
point of entry there should be strong
exterior fencing metal detectors and the
use of new technology okay so let me get
this straight trump wants a single point
of entry strong exterior fencing a metal
detector and technology to prevent
anyone with a weapon trying to enter
he just described a prison but i guess
that shouldn't come as a surprise
considering that the private prison
industry benefited from trump
administration policies to expand
detention centers and increase profits
especially those who donated to trump's
campaign well i can't wait to hear what
else trump is pushing
that's why as part of a comprehensive
school safety plan it's time to finally
allow highly trained teachers to safely
and discreetly concealed
carry wait hold on i thought republicans
said teachers were just liberal hacks
grooming children but now republicans
are totally okay with giving teachers
guns to protect children teachers are
some of the most stressed underpaid and
under-appreciated workforces out there
they should be teaching not acting as
security guards i mean does anyone else
hear how insane this sounds i'm sorry
but i feel like i'm taking crazy pills
oh okay before i go i just want to call
attention to another pathetic excuse for
a human being who's also on the nra
payroll texas senator ted cruz looking
at broken families absent fathers
declining church attendance social media
bullying violent online content
desensitizing the act of murder in video
games chronic isolation need i remind
you ted cruz is the guy who flew to
cancun and abandoned texans while they
froze to death not to mention when he
got caught he blamed it all on his
daughters so
i don't think he's the best person to
listen to about anything by elites i
refer to some of the most powerful
politicians and their allies in the
media many of these same people make
their accusations from behind great
bulwarks of safety from gated
communities equipped with private
security or at the very least from safe
and expensive neighborhoods protected by
high home prices and low crime rates
such people can afford an indulgent
ideology that ignores reality ted cruz
is calling other people elite okay that
is rich because if you looked up elite
in the dictionary you would see ted
cruz's face he's a princeton and harvard
law graduate who lives in a
multi-million dollar home in a very
wealthy community with private security
at this point i think we've had enough
of cruz so let's just go outside and get
some fresh air
whoa were those people protesting the
nra convention well now i'm curious to
know how many people were in attendance
inside the convention oh that is
embarrassing maybe instead of banning
selfie sticks they should have just
banned smartphones because then at least
no one would know they had an awful
turnout well i'm gabe sanchez and this
has been what was
[Music]
that you